over the past year we have achieved huge
and numerous developments chiefly
freedom and independence as we rid our
country of foreign occupation in justice
and depression this is what any people
or country under occupation aspires to
it is a source of pride for us it is
also a blessing
you have been out and about and you can
see for yourselves the huge
transformations in our country in terms
of security it is the first time in 40
years to have a central government
taking control of the whole country
corner to corner inch to inch the
central government which without any
levees or foreign aid is capable of
paying government employees salaries
across all state institutions these are
just a few examples let's talk about
when you came to kabul um
why did the taliban not respect the
agreement that there was signed in doha
why did you use force why did you take
over kabul by force
rather than negotiating your way inside
throughout 14 months since the
withdrawal of the us and nato forces
there has not been a single case of
violation a living proof of such fact is
the host and sponsor the state of cotter
in contrast numerous violations actually
more than 1 000 were committed by the
u.s forces and former kabul government
for example was when biden came to power
he extended the date of the withdrawal
by four months without negotiating with
us let alone the delay in removing names
from the blacklist the delay to release
afghan prisoners there is a long list of
violations
despite our frustrations we preferred
not to resort to violence however the
sudden vacuum in kabul was the reason
for us to step in in addition to the
request made by karzai and abdullah for
us to come and take control you promised
a lot of things you promised peace you
promised rights for afghans you promised
an inclusive government
you promised women's rights how many of
those promises have you kept
the foreign occupation that has been
controlling afghanistan over the past 20
years with their advanced technologies
huge capabilities and resources they
failed throughout that time failed to
restore the security and order our
people are enjoying now
it has been only one year since we
assumed power and the world should not
expect us to achieve all our goals
overnight it is next to impossible
especially when the international
community has not fulfilled promises
including recognition of our rule and
foreign aid
despite the delay on their part we by
the grace of god achieved huge progress
on many fronts now you can see girls
joining universities and schools
needless to say there are many measures
still to be taken in all our ministries
and other state institutions security
and order is the paramount goal does
your family
do the leaders of the taliban who are
under restrictions do they need to be in
government isn't that an impediment
on afghanistan
why aren't other people involved in
taking care of the government
because there are a lot of sanctions
against
many members of this government
till this day the whole world has not
come to a uniform definition of
terrorism it has been the usual habit
that those in power label anyone
standing in their way as a terrorist
enemy hostile etc history has many
examples yasser arafat and nelson
mandela remained for years on the
blacklist later they were awarded the
nobel prize blacklists and sanctions are
nothing but a political tool our
paramount goal was to free our country
of the shackles of occupation to regain
our freedom and independence and that is
what we accomplished now we do not wish
to interfere with other countries and
other people's affairs we and the whole
afghan people regard our leaders highly
our leaders are regarded as heroes as
leaders to freedom and independence
more than three million people are
internally displaced in terms of food
insecurity uh
it's what is considered to be the second
largest crisis food crisis in the world
do you think you're satisfied with what
you've achieved in one year and what are
you doing for the people of afghanistan
as i stated earlier afghanistan today is
totally different from what it was 20
years ago for example the former
government failed to do anything for
mazari sharif they were reeling under
pressures from the occupation
we started to do something in the right
direction now you see minerals and
natural resources are being extracted
using local and foreign companies by the
grace of god through these projects we
are now able to generate revenues for
the functioning of our ministries and
other institutions all these revenues
used to fall into the wrong hands in the
past all the state revenues are now
channeled into the government's treasury
having said that we aspire to enjoy good
and friendly relations with the whole
world we're here to serve our people i
believe we have managed to achieve a lot
for our people but we aspire for more
despite the challenges we are facing
from the international community
including the issue of recognition
very quickly if you could tell us one of
the promises that you made to the
outside community was that the afghan
soil is not going to be used by any
outside groups they're going to be zero
tolerance for any terrorist
organizations or individuals who might
be working against other governments in
the last few weeks we've seen a number
of assassinations take place the leader
of the territory in pakistan has been
killed the leader of al-qaeda has been
killed in kabul
what is your government doing and how is
it going to keep its promise
since the signing of the agreement we
have been honoring all obligations we
dare anybody to give a single example or
a single occasion where our territories
were used to undermine other countries
security the statement made by the
islamic emirate explaining its position
was very clear we are committed to the
doha agreement it clearly sets out the
obligations placed on us as well as the
u.s
if any violation was committed it was
the u.s who entered our territories
without permission even without
notifying us this was a clear violation
on the part of the u.s theirs is a
malicious propaganda aimed at smearing
the image of the islamic emirate we
reject and refute these false claims and
i reiterate we have not violated any of
our obligations under the doha agreement
we are committed to honoring our
obligations and wish to see the other
party honoring theirs and live up to
their responsibilities